All right, so
this seems like a good time to stop and
ask ourselves what have we learned?
>> Oh, you're asking me?
>> I am indeed, I'm sorry.
>> Okay, that's not a problem,
I think I know the answer.
So the first thing is we
relearned everything we learned
from the MDP lessons from before.
So, we learned all
about Scooby Doo MDPs.
>> [LAUGH] I don't think
that's a kind of MDP.
>> It is now.
We should write a paper, quick.
>> And so that included things like
what are states, and transitions, and
rewards, and so forth, right?
>> Right, I think.
>> Anything else?
>> Well, I think we learned
a bunch of new things.
So for me,
I learned all about Q functions
>> Mm-hm
>> I learned about continuations And,
in general, when I think about that,
I really learned about what
the Bellman Equations,
as opposed to equation,
are really trying to capture for you.
Even more than we did when we
talked about that with MDPs.
>> Alright, so deeper understanding of
the Bellman Equation and how it relates
the rewards in this infinite
sequence of rewards to each other.
Yeah, that's sort of
what I was going for.
>> Yeah, and I think that's a lot.
And I think I learned
that notation matters.
>> [LAUGH] Okay.
[LAUGH]
>> No,
remember we talked about
the reward in the Scooby Doo MDP.
We talked about R is a function of S.
And when we talked about Q functions and
C functions in the Bellman equations,
we went to R being S of a.
And even though we had mentioned
before that they were mathematically
equivalent, it turns out,
just like sometimes thinking about Q,
sometimes thinking about C might be
better than thinking about V or U.
It turns out that sometimes thinking
about R of S of a, Is better than
thinking about R of S, even if they
really are mathematically equivalent.
>> And in some sense it
doesn't matter though, right,
because we actually were able
to do similar things with the R,
S as we are with the R, S, a.
>> True, although, you know what,
that's not really notation, right?
Notation is used doing V instead of U.
This is really a representation.
>> Ooh.
Representation matters.
>> Yeah, and I think that's
actually a pretty important lesson.
And when I think about some of the other
things that we know about reinforcement
learning, the representation is
going to make a huge difference.
>> I think that's right.
I think that's a good lesson for
I want to say AI in general, but
certainly machine learning.
>> Okay, well that seemed like
a profound point to end on.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, cool.
So we'll pick it up with
reinforcement learning next time.
>> Done.
Let's do that.
Have a good time, Michael.
>> You too.
>> Bye.